on the way to the airport I had a car
accident you demoted because you missed
a week off work after a car accident
yeah I didn't feel valued so you quit
your job to do the property training and
now you're controlling how many
properties 26 and turning over how much
30k a month every single one of my deals
are no money down deal I've literally
invested zero of my own money in all my
deals you have to be passionate you have
to be willing to do whatever it takes
and then just be around
winners
[Music]
congratulations on making it to win us
on a Wednesday hi thank you you have
been working your butt off this last
year absolutely and I think one of the
things that we all know you're for in
the property Community is your work
ethic because you literally move from
London to Huddersfield why did you do
that when I joined I just wanted to I
thought I found that London was very
competitive the market and plus I had
families up harders field and I just
knew it well and you can get to
different places like Leeds Manchester
Bradford and there was just so much
opportunity there so I moved up north
it's interesting you did that and quite
a few people have done this yes you know
they've theyve or they've got like a
massive deal or a massive connection or
a landlord and they've just moved to the
area and that shows proper commitment
what were you doing prior to going in
full-time into property like what was
your what's your background so I was
working for an IT company okay um so it
was a very steady job I was working from
home most of the time but I could go in
the office um it was very comfortable
but I kind of find it a bit um boring or
yeah yeah yeah so you're working
full-time in it in it what kind of
salary were you making about 36 okay so
normal salary normal salary living in
London living in London cool normal
normal setup yes yes what was it that
gave you that to kind of suddenly want
to get into property and how did it all
come about with work right um I went to
on holiday and I had a car accident so I
missed my flight coming back and by the
time I got back to the UK they already
demoted me and like gave someone else my
role they didn't really believe me even
though I sent them pictures and then
that kind of just made me like okay I
really don't want to be working for a
company that don't really care about me
per se that's how I kind of felt demoted
yeah because you missed a week off work
after a car accident yeah I missed my on
the way to the airport I had a car
accident wasn't big but it did delay me
and I missed my flight yeah and um yeah
by the time I got back my role was taken
from me and everything did you lose your
job over there no I didn't lose my job
you just got a new job which was less
pay no they kept my pay they just
basically removed me from my roll and
gave it to someone else and gave me a
lesser roll wow um so I wasn't really
happy about that and then I wanted to
come to the deal selling master class
right and he said no oh that that's not
acceptable so then I hand in my notice I
said you got two days and so you quit
your job to do the property training
yeah I did which was only like a few
days training so you quit your whole job
over that I remember that I remember
that yeah and didn't you sell your first
deal on the program absolutely high five
made four grand made four grand on the
program on the wow the program yeah do
you know what there do you think a lot
of people live their whole life just
working in a job not being appreciated
not being valued but they never know
that there's anything different they
don't know there's something else that
they can do absolutely I think I think
for me I didn't feel valued so I'm just
like okay what's the risk versus reward
cuz I was spending days just watching
your deal selling masterclass and that
training is very long it's like 70
something hours you do the online deal
selling master class I was watching it
day by like I was working from home
watching it over and over step by step
so by by the end of it I was just like
really boosted up anyway and I felt like
everything that you was training online
I could do right so when I was watching
it and I was thinking okay lar you can
do this why stay here and be unhappy why
don't you try so the next deal selling
course was going to be like four months
I didn't want to stay four months and do
it later I want to do it now I was
already ready to go so and so you did
the online training yes got all the
theory then you wanted to do the iners
your work said no and you said bye
you're fired I said boss I said I said
bye but eventually they did give me the
days off and ask me to stay two months
before actually leaving all right they
always do that though don't they they'll
say you can't and then when you well
I'll leave then they okay you can all
right we'll pay you more we do believe
you we do believe that you had a car
accident exactly so um and then because
I quit my job it made me more hungry so
I actually went to Somerset to view that
property that weekend before the deal
saleing MasterCard cuz I was like I have
no job I finished my online training
what's the worst that can happen did you
come to a crash course first or did you
go straight into the Advent I did a
crash course I did crash course the like
two months before and how was that it
was amazing it was like a wet Christmas
party from we drove up to um Manchester
from London and believe it or not but
the crash course was 4 minutes walk away
from a hotel that's cool so I thought I
might as well go to the absolutely it be
rude not to so yeah and now then so it's
been how long has it been since you
since you sold your first deal and you
kind of went fully in so I've sold my
first deal in February so this year this
year so it's what been about 8 nine
months now and now you're controlling
how many properties 26 26 properties yes
and turning over how much 30k a month
roughly with a profit per month for just
for you for you about seven Grand about
seven Grand a month which is like
Madness yes that's incredible and you're
doing the deal selling still I do like
once so one one a month but since the
acpp I've been structuring my business
to now focus more on Deal selling as
well wow how many deals have you sold
today uh seven seven deals yeah so so
you're basically you're full-time in
property financially independent yes
making more money than most people that
have worked all their life in the
corporate world yes um so how did you do
it what are the tips what are the tips
be passionate I think for me it just
it's because I'm passionate so
everything that that came to me was
because people knew who I was and they
saw how passionate I was about
everything so even my first
rent to rent it was because of my
passion someone said I was like okay I
found this rent to rent I have no money
quit my job I need some money and a
friend of mine she saw how passionate I
was she really believed in me she said I
know someone who may be able to invest
in you so go and see this person I spoke
to them just you know just like how I Am
Naturally and I just you know laid
everything out and within like 24 hours
the money was in my bank for the first
rent how much how much did you have to
raise for that5 Grand £5,000 and you
raised that super quick super quick and
you what about the deal that you sold
the very first deal at the deal Master
Class how did that happen how did that
happen so when I went to Somerset to
find that deal that weekend after
quitting my job I came back I checked it
with um Simon he said this is a great
deal so I just put my hand up and I was
like you wasn't choosing me at first I
was like I've got all money out deal and
I screamed out um but then I used that
money towards joining the academy and
it's just the best decision but what's
interesting is I didn't notice you at
first but you kept on yeah hey I've got
this deal this can't ignore it but
that's how you have to be I think to be
successful you've got to sometimes be
prepared to be courageous and even
sometimes put yourself down people's
throats and certainly in Britain and
certainly when it comes to money money's
tooo yeah we're all about being humble
yeah we're even at school it's like
don't step out you know don't step out
the lines put your hand up when you want
to go to the toilet but in business
you've got to be loud you've got to let
people know what you're doing and you've
got to be courageous because it's so
embarrassing people people would find it
so embarrassing to say I'm going to do
this and I'm going to do this and then
they fail and everyone saw them fail and
everyone saw them really try and fail
and I think the the the fear of failure
stops a lot of people doing that but
where did that courage come from where
did that confidence come from right at
the beginning I think for me failure was
not an option and it still isn't an
option for me I was so ready um to go
and also when everyone had their deals
and you're like does anyone have any
better deal and I was thinking my deal
is better than that you know and I was
like he better choose me cuz my Deal's
good yeah and I was sing multiple deals
as well in the program um what did you
think when when when you saw me selling
deal deal deal deal just selling deals
live it just put I just knew that I
could do it and I it just made
everything just come together so it just
made it all worth it like okay I can
visually see from a to to be how to do
it yeah especially when I sell your deal
exactly right so 4,000 bang ,000 and you
put that into the Academy of course bang
it just felt like the right thing to do
and obviously it was scary at first
because investing in the academy is
expensive and I don't have a job yeah um
so for me it was like ooh but I was
ready to put everything in it but again
that's courageous there again cuz I gu
another thing people will think I don't
want to step out and tell everyone what
I'm going to do cuz then I might fail
and look stupid I don't want to
everything I've on myeducation and
invest in myself CU it might not work
and when you're when you're driven by it
what if it goes wrong what if it doesn't
work you're almost dooming yourself from
the start whereas what I think what you
did is you said what if it what if it
will yeah right or it has to it's going
to I'm going to make it happen you know
so you sold your first deal made £4,000
what was the deal something yeah it was
a seven bed HMO so it was a five bed
that would be converted into a seven bed
HMO like a br HMO thing it yeah viewed
it got all the yes I was just like you
know reading all the numbers off when
you was ask to me and you had to you
said what's the vision and I was able to
show you it was just great and that's
another thing you need confidence but
you also need the knowledge to back up
your confidence which is why education
is important if I said to you what's the
vision what's the numbers how much is it
going to cost to re and you'd have
fallen apart yeah yeah you can be as
confident as you want but if you Ain got
the knowledge to back up the confidence
I was reeling it off I was like yeah
this this this so your rental portfolio
is that based in Huddersfield no no no I
have none in Huddersfield believe it or
not um I've got four in Manchester okay
and then we have the 22 in Bradford and
I've got a couple pending I'm just
setting them up at the moment youve got
a couple lease options pending as well
yeah a couple lease options just making
sure going for the legal team just
making sure and there really good so and
considering this is your first year yeah
yeah it is madness and people ask me
they say what happens to the people on
winners on a Wednesday like down the
line damn I could do winners Wednesday
graduate part two yeah cuz if you look
at the list of people and then you look
how they are two years after their
interview yeah they are crazy successful
it's crazy what well I got my first keys
to my essay I think on the 28th of April
mhm and that was what November yeah and
it's just crazy what six seven months
can do yeah when you work your ass off
yeah investing yourself oh believe me we
know that the first thing I said work
hard surround yourself with a good team
invest in yourself and be courageous
absolutely if you do that you almost
guaranteed to win absolutely um was
there any
times I know you so you I know you you
Su quite quick for you happened quite
quick but were there any times at the
beginning when you were thinking gez
this is not working I need to get a job
again or did that not happen no and I
was saying this at the networking event
in Manchester with hour guys um there
was one day it was just just everything
was just overwhelming cuz I'm a one man
van and managing everything and I just
remember waking up and saying I don't
want to do this I'm going to quit and
then I just for a quick second I thought
about applying for a job doing an
interview and I snapped out of it
straight away cuz I'm like never I'm not
doing that so this has to work yeah so
no as as you've probably heard me say
before it's hard being rich but it's
also hard being poor absolutely so you
got to choose do I want the hardship and
the responsibility of running a business
and having loads of tenants and 26 props
to manage which is going to be tough to
set that up and systemize that but it's
also going to be tough to have a job
absolutely and you just got to choose
which one you want and I'd rather the
one that brings me in 30 grand a month
thank you very much thank you very much
so you do a lot of social housing as
well don't you yes I'm around quite a
lot of people around me are in Social um
supported living yeah so I am learning
from them so sometimes I also do like
two two one two shifts a week where I
work in that environment with my friends
and they training me so even um the
investor who has the 22 units we've got
two of a block of two that we're doing
supported living on so floting floating
support guaranteed money yes um even the
block of 20 um we are in process of also
turning that into supported living so
profit wise is going to be really good
in the next probably like six seven
months what are then so you've got some
of them are supported living yeah um
some of them are what they service
accommodation yeah most of them are
service accommodation I have also had
midterm tenants in the block of 20 I
kind of
who's these in Bradford Bradford who's
going to Bradford on service
accommodation I'm not being funny but
like I can't imagine you got many
tourists in Bradford Bradford or
Barbados you know well it's right next
to the football stadium which is great
um so it's in a great location I do have
to be honest I have a really high repeat
um guest rate in in the Bradford unit we
have even currently we have about four
in the sa section that's been there for
like 3 months it just keep extending
every month that's not bad yeah and then
eight um another section of eight we
have them for like six to 12 months as
well you do as well some interesting
that you do is you do a lot of
management so you um some of your
properties are rent to rents correct me
if I'm wrong but quite a lot of them are
just strip management where you just say
to the landlord look you want to get a
grand a month for probably Bradford less
you want £500 a month for this apartment
yeah yeah let me do it a service to
accommodation yeah and I'll take a
percentage is that what you do that's
what I do and even to last night I came
down um I was working with a guest who
stayed in my property and it was my
first time doing like um charging a
deposit and the lot box wasn't working I
thought the check-in process wasn't
perfect but she just loved the way I
dealt with the situation she called me
as soon as she checked in and she said L
Cara um do you manage this building I
said yeah I've got a few properties in
this building um she's like um me and my
husband would love for you to you know
manage some of us wow and so at even
though it was a disaster she still said
that it wasn't necess a disaster she
just loved the way how every issue that
she had I was able to like stay on the
phone guide her through it she even
enjoyed paying the deposit not enjoyed
but she she was happy no but she was so
happy that I charged a deposit CU in her
head she's thinking if she manages my
property she's also going to charge a
deposit you take phot ID and stuff yes I
take so she saw your process yes I do
that though when I stay property
sometimes I'll be thinking damn this
person doesn't know what they're doing
terrible they didn't ask me for any ID
they didn't take my car details they
even know who I am I could trash this
place and this is terrible or I'll get
there I was staying at a property in I
went to Disneyland last year in uh in
France and I went to take the property
there was no lot box yeah and I was
thinking they didn't have any
instructions I messaged them and they
were like oh yeah we'll be there in an
hour we'll come and let you in the guy
physically at to drive to open I'm
thinking this is this is ter ridiculous
it needs to come on the service
accommodation training baby what's this
so your lady saw your setup and even
though there was a few hiccups because
you were so proactive and that's another
thing in business is really important is
I've noticed we we we do a lot of
training at the ACP about customer
service yes yes and and about customers
and obsessing over your customers your
customers will forgive you for making
mistakes as long as you address it and
it's how you react to it Abs if you make
a mistake and they can't get a hold of
you and you're like la la la and you
respond terribly but if you respond well
then they actually end up loving you
yeah yeah I am obsessed about my
customers amazing I'm glad to hear that
hence why I'm like super host and Airbnb
with' been like four months I know but
super host yeah awesome you've got to be
obsessed with your customers cuz they're
people paying you of course so this lady
then so she was a guest but then she
said I also own properties can you
manage mine yeah absolutely to be honest
they um they were staying up my property
CU they were renovating an apartment but
that apartment is not even their main
home they just stay in it temporary
until they buy their dream home but
since then they've also bought another
property another apartment next to that
building which I'm just almost finished
the refurb light refurb on it then
staging it and then managing it so she
wants me to do the full thing she just
gives me the keys okay I want to know
laraa I want to know the different types
of guests that would stay in service
accommodation because one of the
misconceptions about service
accommodation is that you only get
tourists so people be thinking oh
Bradford is going to be terrible cuz
there's no tourist that and that's why I
said that cuz people think that yeah
yeah so tell me the different types of
guests yeah so I don't get much tourists
in my area so in Bradford for example I
have a lot of probably healthc Care
Professionals who actually stay we have
why why would a healthcare professional
not have their own house because they're
traveling from far they like to do their
Monday to Friday um so I get a lot of
that Monday to Friday booking W so they
they coming to work at a hospital yes
but maybe they've just got a shift for
the week or whatever but they don't live
in Bradford so State your place how much
do you charge per night how much which
one which area Bradford in Bradford
during the week is about 70 plus
cleaning so it's quite low um but in
Manchester I charge probably about 120
okay night and for Bradford you're
you're managing the properties managing
that yeah is does does do the landlords
love you oh my gosh so the the Bradford
landlord they were able to like
refinance um their property and get a
valuation because we set it up so nice
they were just so impressed the value of
the property went up okay I'm going to
talk about that in a minute more guests
so you got Healthcare professionals who
else so in my Manchester Block it's
Monday to Friday the car park is full of
work vans from 6 p.m. cuz it's just
contractors and then on weekend is um
where I get my let's say tourist or
someone weekenders yeah they're come to
do some shopping in Manchester or
whatever yeah or events do you get
relocators yeah I get get relocated to
me about what that means so these are
people who are in the process of moving
houses so they might have maybe
refurbing a house it's not ready um for
whatever reason they need a temporary
stay a lot of the time they do extend
for relocators it's really good have
yeah they're moving house yeah they
might think oh I need somewh for a few
weeks but a few weeks turn or a few
months cuz the work's not done and
you're getting paid 100 quid a night
yeah yeah but why would but I guess the
thing is they're paying for flexibility
aren't they yeah if they rented a house
they' have to sign into an as cont for
12 months furnish the place get Wi-Fi
you're giving them home from home AB
yeah absolutely so so how do you pitch
landlords how do I pitch the landlord I
think for me at the moment it's really
easy it's easier because I have the
proof of the portfolio right um and I'm
able to show you know what I do and so
I'm a landlord I'm in Manchester yeah
yeah I got a little apartment block yeah
yeah with six Apartments yeah yeah and
you're pitching me for management yeah
how do you approach me so I've done this
recently there's a there's a block down
the road so I just I just went in I said
hey um I'm laala hold on hold on when in
where to the apartment block or yeah
there was an apartment block and they're
doing a referb work on it and I how do
you know who the owner even is cuz the
builders told me he'll be back next week
right so you approach the builders okay
this is all part of it though this is
the secret right here cuz a l people
just like what what you just turn so you
approach you see the builders and you
say I want to talk to the owner and they
say oh the owner's called Andy he's
going to be here on Tuesday afternoon
okay then you come back on Tuesday ask
okay and then what do you say you see he
withy yeah I just asked you know what
are you what's the plan with the what
you plan to do here and you know are you
renting it out are you selling or you
you know so I just ask the the general
questions we build a report and then I
go in and I said you know you know that
that building it's a historical building
so everyone kind of know it I said you
know I manage those properties and you
know this is what we do and I'm looking
at the moment we're filled with
contractors and we would love to get
some more properties um we take IDs you
know just trying to make him know that
it's very professional um there's even
another property in London where um it's
atired landlord someone did an service
accommodation before and they did a
terrible job they didn't take ID there
was parties so he was a bit like
skeptical but then when I say if you do
it with me we're taking IDs we're taking
deposits you know we have doorbells we
have um lots of yeah there's a lot to it
absolutely sticking it on Airbnb no it's
not and that's that's you've invested in
your education you've learned how to do
it properly and now you're saying to the
landlords look if you rent it normal
yeah yeah you're going to get maybe
£1,000 an apartment mhm if you rent it
on service accommodation you'll get
3,000 exactly but you don't know how to
do it but I do let me manage it what do
you charge percentage wise um it varies
so anywhere from 15 to 30% 30%
mhm that's high how do you justify
charging 30% um so the 30% is mainly of
the supported living one just because um
it's guaranteed income and I've been
working with the same investor for a
while yeah so and and and how do you
know whether to pitch them on rent to
rent or just straight
management it's difficult you have to
ask what they want I think it's a
conversation so you don't go in and just
tell them this is what I charge you ask
them questions right so for example my
pre my the recent one I'm working on for
them they they would usually do B toet
and quite a lot of people approached
them for B toet but when I showed them
the
figures um you know and minus my
percentage they're still making over two
grand a month their mortgage is like way
low so they're making a lot more profit
they're going to make more money from
giving you the management probably yeah
but then some landlords just want it
guaranteed yeah and some landlords just
think look just give me my grand
anything you make above that you can
keep but I want to know I'm getting my
grand yeah yeah but the these landlords
some landlords are happy to take a bit
of risk and some are not so what the
advantages is for you from managing
instead of doing rent to rent um you
don't have to put any of your money in
the risk is very low so I was saying to
the guys this week that I didn't realize
but every single one of my deals a no
money down deal I've literally invested
zero pounds of my own money in all my
deals um all the properties I have
because there's no risk well there is
risk but cuz I borrowed the money and
have to pay it back but yeah I haven't
with management though there's no money
at all is there no money at all and then
we've rent to rent you've borrowed the
money borrowed the money yeah so you've
put in no money but you did put money in
for your education right for my
education how did you afford that where
did you get that money from just
borrowed the
money who did you borrow it from um the
bank oh wow did you what what what what
interest were they charging um 6.8 or
something that's peanuts though isn't it
yeah that's peanuts and how much did you
have to borrow the whole 12 you sold a
deal sold the deal I think I only
borrowed like six grand so you bored
about so you about six grand put two
grand already and then bit of savings
sold a deal but the majority alone well
half alone yeah 6% that's Madness is do
you know what I find me interesting did
you go to university yeah how what did
you study travel management how much was
it like I know you probably got a
student L but how much like was the was
the uni course um it was like nine grand
a year and how many years did you do
three years so that's like what n 27
Grand cuz the thing is if you do travel
management you you you know where I'm
going with I know where am I going me he
like are you earning that money back for
a travel are you no no did has it helped
you at all
though no absolutely not but what's
interesting is like I bet no one judged
you for that decision no everyone's
happy that I went to UNI what how did
you get people judging you when join the
academy to be honest I think I didn't
even the noise wasn't even there if
someone didn't have any opinions it
didn't matter to me talk me through your
experience of the academy and what has
happened exactly okay so my honest
opinion is at the very start because
everything happened so quickly I didn't
utilize the academy because and it's the
reason why I was so stressed at the
beginning because I'm not utilizing the
tools that I had so I had this block of
20 and I was just like drowning you know
like trying to figure it out and I spoke
to your mom and then she kind of like
break it down to me you know and I start
networking and speaking to other Academy
members and then all of a sudden my you
know everything just I start to
systemize because okay what do you do
what do you do what do you do and then
everyone start to give their opinions or
just give tips and then that just helped
me so the academy is been F has been
fantastic especially like recently now
that I'm utilizing it more networking
and just speaking to everyone else and
just yeah what would you say to your
year younger self who's about to embark
on the journey that you've embarked on
go for it like don't hesitate um I'm
just so happy that I did that I'm
thinking this time last year what was I
doing just watching your video on
YouTube this madness I I didn't expect
that this would be me a year later and
even today when I went to the financial
um you did the finance um fin challenge
yeah no no at Finance no on the deal
selling Master Class you do a oh yeah
freom for intensive yeah right and you
had to write down your goals yes right
I WR I written down that I wanted to be
on winners and a Wednesday within a year
but it's happened so quick I that's
crazy yeah manifestation manifestation
and I written down that I wanted to get
two um service accommodation by the end
of April CU I received my last paycheck
the end of March and I actually did so
it was just crazy yeah do you think that
is there anything you would do different
with your approach and with your
strategies of what you've done or do you
think you've played it just perfect um I
would I mean I I everything that's gone
bad or anything that I've struggled with
has just made me improve but if I was to
do it again I would definitely utilize
the academy more at the start of my
journey and stop being shy per se why
was that was it just you just didn't
want to like bother people or something
cuz I always say like every single
Monday I'm like don't feel like you're
bothering us that it go again and again
and again because many Mentor unlimited
but some people just feel like a bit
like bit awkward I don't know why some
people really don't that some people
just like man I'll book them into every
day myself most people probably are like
that but there's always the polite
people sometimes that be like that's me
I'm the mark but now you realize it's
all good yeah because even you know
you've you've spoken about me getting
staff and building a team yeah and I've
just put it out there and now I've got
someone in from the academy who's going
to help me organize help me with my
business structure cuz you know
organizational because that's what she
does in her noral dayto job and I needed
help with it so the fact that I'm I'm
speaking to people and telling people
what I need is so many people willing to
help you in the academy so just talk and
just yeah what about acpp what is that
and what happened it's amazing why don't
you do it more often why is it longer um
it's just a two days we we come down to
your house and you put us in a hot seat
and you just ask us so much about the
business but not not only do you just
ask us about you know different
questions and you know challenges but at
the end of it for example after you you
heard how a mess my life is um you said
Lala what do you need help with I said
probably Staffing and organizational
structure and then on the board you were
just you know helping me you know this
is how you get your stuff and this is
how you organize and which was just
fantastic and then you able to learn
from other people's and the other people
in the room is ridiculous isn't it
everyone in that room was was there
anyone in the room that was not
financially Fred I think there was I
think every single there's about what 22
24 yeah I think everyone's over 5 grand
I don't think there was no one like
below that and it's difficult to be
around I mean when people first joined
the academy like you mentioned at first
it's oh I'm trying to find your feet
sometimes but like after a few months
when you're around people constantly
that are making 5 Grand 10 grand 20
grand a month it kind of begins to feel
normal yeah like even now your mom was
like my my next goal should be 50k a
month and but I can see it I can
visually see that I can make 50k a month
before when I came in you say what's
your next goal and I was saying
something like 10K across each business
but it's like no 50k but I realized 10K
I'm almost there so 50k is the next goal
and I have to set it big you know what
is it that drives you then where does
the motivation come from oh I want to
I've always wanted to live a life where
I have a business running for me making
money and I'm able to travel the world
and just live life on my terms makes
sense I like that that makes sense and
do you think that having a goal is
important because a lot of people talk
about having like why power does does is
that does that resonate for you or is it
just winning it's not winning you have
to have a goal I just remember back from
when I first finished college and I
wanted to get my first car if I didn't
have that goal I wouldn't have got it
within nine months I pass my lessons got
my first car within nine months of me
setting that goal something I want if
you don't know what you're working
towards just working yeah you need to
have something that's driving you how
long ago did you finish
University uh 8 years ago okay so not
that long no what's next for you then
what's the next plan 2024 what's the
focus 2024 I want to start owning you do
you own one house though right I do you
own one and control 26 yeah and make
something crazy a month I can't remember
now 7 Grand profit but yeah yeah it's
increasing you want to start owning more
yeah I want to start owning um
especially in this market it's a buy
market so want to start the next
strategy would be raising Finance yeah
um and going into know you know how you
told me that it's much easier to get
rent to rents and to persuade landlords
because you've already got them yes
you'll also find 100% buying properties
yes is much easier when you currently
control properties okay and raising
Finance for things like development
deals is much easier when you've raised
Finance for rent to rents previously
because you you're in the game the fact
you're now in the game you're doing it
you sat here on Windows on a Wednesday
you know it's going to be very easy for
you to to raise violence you you will
and you'll be a to get the deals because
you're on the academy we're about to
help you look at them review them help
package them um but yeah that seems like
a good Next Step yeah yeah so that's the
plan for next year so final pieces of
wisdom before we wrap up um just for
anyone yeah for anybody watching this
anybody watching this sees what you're
saying and thinks damn I want to do the
same thing I want to get out of my job I
want to be around winners I want to be
successful definitely get the training
um without the training I wouldn't be
here um and the other thing is you have
to be passionate you have to be willing
to do whatever it takes there's a lot of
people who want to get into property but
they're scared of Letting Go whether
it's the job or but you have to be so
passionate you just know it will work
set your goal get the training and then
just be around winners love that Academy
yeah I love that and and and I really
appreciate you coming in and taking the
time to share to give back if you're
watching this and you want to come and
spend a day with me doing property
training like laa did it all starts with
the property investors crash course so
I'm going to leave a link in the
description where you can spend the day
with me for one pound one pound for a
ticket connect with laala dream big
kickass I'll see you there